so let's move on to some of the other
reaction because as i said even though
we don't only want to focus
on the negative on the people who go
purely to politics we have to understand
it
right like this is the give the devil
his do thing see what the people who who
really are wrong who use everything for
their own
purposes see what they're saying because
if you really see it and you and you
understand where they're coming from
then maybe you can respond to it
properly so there were i mean we could
have spent literally 10 hours today i
could have spent i could have spent 24
hours today just reading you horrific
tweets and facebook posts and instagram
messages from politicians and blue check
people the worst sort of responses
saying that republicans have blood on
their hand i mean just the most vile you
know
that you know certain politicians or
murderers are just the worst
worst worst sort of stuff
um we could have done that but we're
only going to select a few here uh here
is squad member progressive and marxist
communist socialist
ilhan omar from minneapolis minnesota
who destroyed that uh city and state by
the way
she's responding to a tweet here's a guy
by the name of perry stein and it's
quote two uvalde police officers and a
school resource officer fired at the
shooter but it did not stop him from
entering the building and then he links
to a washington post article the point
being that there were some officers
there and they were not able to stop
this there are some questions as to
whether they did everything they could
do et cetera et cetera connor can we
throw up her tweet again so i can get to
that
she retweeted it and responded honestly
every republican who said this is how
you stop mass shootings need to be voted
out of office their pro-gun agenda is
dangerous and it's time for sensible gun
reform laws in american enough okay so
first off this thing about sensible gun
law reforms okay it means nothing what
they usually say is common sense uh gun
law reforms
common sense i mean we have background
checks right we have checks on people's
mental health you cannot create a
perfect system you cannot do it there
are always going to be people who slip
through the cracks there's always going
to be someone who buys a gun legally and
then someone who's able to get that gun
that maybe lives in their house and
finds the key or whatever it might be
they're also a crazy
crazy amount of illegal guns in cities
like chicago that are murdering people
every single weekend find out if most of
those guns or that are killing people in
chicago are legally bought or illegally
bought they're usually illegally bought
which goes to show you that no matter
how many laws you have bad people will
get
bad things pull up or tweet sorry one
more time on the tweet uh so their
pro-gun agenda is dangerous and trium
and time for sensible gun reform laws in
america the pro-gun agenda is an
interesting way of putting this thing
what she should be saying is the
pro-second amendment that you have the
right to defend yourself and perhaps
if this school
had had other policies if this talented
at other policies texas texas has pretty
good gun policies but perhaps everyone
watching this wherever your kids go to
school whatever synagogue you go to or
church you go to or
community group that you go to if they
thought about things a little bit
differently why is it that there are
armed guards outside of barack obama's
house why are there armed guards outside
of the u.s capitol building why are
there armed guards
virtually everywhere where politicians
exist right we suddenly we can find
money for that but we can't find money
uh to put armed guards or a local
community member who is armed it doesn't
have to be some outsourced thing it
could hopefully maybe it's a father a
retired police officer in the community
et cetera et cetera that could guard
these schools and do better
defense of these schools rather than
taking away people's god-given rights
which is really what the push will now
be i mean the push obviously now by the
left is going to be republicans they're
they're of course they're racists and
nazis but they're also murderers and we
should take their guns away and thank
god we have uh the second amendment and
thank god we have the first amendment
which is defended by the second
amendment so we can say what we think
and we can still defend ourselves and
then if there are little marginal places
to talk about what we can do around some
of the gun laws and by the way i bought
a gun in california it was incredibly
hard and took an extremely long time is
it easier to buy a gun in texas yes it
is and perhaps should we look at some of
the ancillary things around that perhaps
we should but that's not really what
this is about